this week the clark county school
district board of trustees will take on
some controversial agenda items these
surround dr jarrah's employment is
superintendent and allegations of a
hostile work environment katie houston
is live in studio tonight with a look at
this week's board mini kate yes this
thursday will be three weeks since dr
jarrah was fired from his role as
superintendent in a 4-3 vote now trustee
irene cepeda who originally voted in
favor of firing him is requesting a
re-vote there are three major items on
thursday's school board agenda trustees
could choose an outside expert to do an
investigation into the allegations of a
hostile work environment there will also
be a discussion about reconsidering the
vote on dr jarrah's termination and
potentially a discussion or appointment
of an interim superintendent after dr
jarrah's firing 8 news now exclusively
obtained a letter from his attorney
where he accused the board of a breach
of contract due to harassment a hostile
work environment and retaliation he's
seeking 2 million dollars in addition to
his contract payout i was very
surprised
and
i just
was very caught off guard by that i
wasn't caught off guard by the part
about the payout and everything because
i pretty much understand
contracts but
that part i was
very very surprised despite this the
board will hold two separate votes on
jarrah's employment on thursday first
the trustees will vote to bring the
agenda item back if it passes trustees
will vote on whether or not jarrah will
keep his position
since doctor jar is firing there have
been concerns over the large raises
given to his executive team and the
conduct of school board trustees board
president linda cavazos touched on both
of those issues within the past week